well it's summertime and that means that
uh it's hot outside if you hadn't
noticed that's generally how it works
it's generally how it has worked as long
as the Earth has had Seasons
um it's you know summer time and then it
gets hot and that's like it's a it's
kind of a it's a it's a process that
we've seen play out a few times now at
least and with the summer season comes
certain Traditions people go on summer
vacations and they go to the pool and go
to the beach and uh the more stylish men
break out their cargo shorts and all the
rest of it lots of great wonderful
traditions and then there's the not so
great modern summer tradition of
panicking hysterically because it's hot
outside this is when the media as it
does every year claims that the hot
weather is a sign of our impending uh
planetary Doom so here's CNN just a
quick clip will play for you reporting
on our quote heat hell that's what
they're calling it it's not summer it's
not just hot out it's a heat hell
uh watch
these long stretches of extreme heat are
what they see as cause for alarm that
extreme heat is not just being felt here
in the United States it's being felt by
millions of people all around the world
as the heat wave sweeps across parts of
Europe and Asia too one top climate
group warns that quote heat hell is
worldwide at the moment and that those
extreme temperatures are nothing short
of dangerous Bill Weir we don't usually
see these record-breaking temperatures
that we usually until later in the
summer why is this summer expected to be
hotter than last summer cooling patterns
in the Pacific there which actually hit
a lot of the pent-up energy in the
oceans which have been hiding a lot of
the heat for the last century or so
right now every second of every day our
planet absorbs as much extra heat as 10
Hiroshima sized atomic bombs per second
and now we're seeing the full result of
that now we have Wildfire smoke which is
a result of drier forests up in Canada
and easier burning conditions there we
have those devastating flash floods that
took the lives of those children as you
were describing north of Philadelphia
those are the results but heat is really
the engine of all of this a warmer
Planet holds too much water in some
places not enough in others and the rate
that it's going up now the scientists
are used to seeing sort of ocean
temperature records broken by a half a
degree
it's been Shattered by five degrees in
the North Atlantic
so in other words it's hot uh yes it is
hot the hottest it's ever been they tell
us it's never been hotter than this
representative ilhan Omar tweeted this
this is the claim that she's making and
not just her she said the Earth just
broke the record for the hottest day in
000 years
in fact we broke in on three separate
days we broke it I think she meant to
say we broke it on three separate days
National Climate emergency now
wow
the hottest day in 120 000 years now I
mean that sounds pretty bad I admit if
we just experienced the hottest day you
know 120 000 years then uh then
something's going on like that's that's
a that's bad news
probably we still couldn't do anything
about it but you can't actually do
anything about it but that would be bad
news the hottest day in 120 000 years
that I mean that's significant at the
very least uh but before you go building
your Ark in preparation for the coming
worldwide floods from the uh polar ice
caps melting and all the rest of it you
should take some solace in the fact that
what ilhan Omar has claimed here is
total absolute nonsense okay that's the
one there's really only one problem with
it the one problem is that it's
completely bogus other than that it's
it's it's true other than the fact that
it's entirely false it's actually true
now how do I know that it's bogus well
because needless to say
we do not have daily temperature records
dating back 120 000 years okay so you
can't you can't say it's the hottest day
in 20 000 years because that would
require you to know how hot it has been
every day for the last 120 000 years and
you don't know that nobody does
in fact we can't get anywhere close to
that in terms of our records
and that's why it's not possible to go
and look and find out what the weather
was like on say I don't know August 7th
in the year 4000 BC
much less the year 40 000 BC that
information does not exist we have no
idea it was not recorded so what the
hell is she babbling about I mean where
is Omar and where's the rest of the
media getting this is she getting it
from her own fevered imagination sort of
but but not entirely Her Imagination is
being fed by the media so the hill for
example published an article with this
headline a couple weeks ago and here's
the headline
we're experiencing Earth's hottest
weather in 120 000 years and it's just
getting started so that's that's
probably pretty directly where she got
it from
although even there you see it's it's
that's not exactly the same claim she
said this is the hottest day in 120 000
years and but the headline is we're
experiencing Earth's hottest weather
which is a little bit more vague
um but even so how do they know that
I mean uh how could they possibly know
that that we're experiencing the hottest
weather 120 000 years well they answer
that question or they pretend to answer
it anyway with this so I'm reading now
it says
how can experts be so confident of these
bold assertions as a climate specialist
I'll do my best to explain it's all
fairly simple and fully expected by the
climate science community
first researchers know using
observations that temperatures over the
past decade have been warmer than any
ever seen since record keep and begin in
the 1800s since then Earth has worn by
1.2 degrees Celsius or 2 degrees
Fahrenheit scientists also know through
sophisticated methods of examining
copious climate clues in proxy data like
tree rings ice cores ocean sediments Etc
that Earth's average temperature has not
been this warm since the Ice Age ended
20 000 years ago between 10 000 years
ago in today's rapid man-made warming
Earth's average temperature was
relatively constant allowing human
civilization to thrive there were
disruptive Regional cooling episodes
like the disparate uh little Ice Age
events but the impact on overall Global
temperature was relatively minor
since at the peak of the last ice age
Earth's average temperature is about 10
degrees cooler than today and it's not
been this warm since the last ice age we
call that time the last interglacial in
between glacial periods which peaked
around 125 000 years ago okay
so that's it that's the uh that's the
science using proxy data like tree rings
and ocean sediments scientists can come
up with a guess
as to the average global temperature
dating back thousands of years
supposedly my friends over at genucel
sold out of their Dark Spot Corrector
and our listeners have been begging for
a restock well I have great news just in
time for the summer it's back in stock
Jenny cell's famous Dark Spot Corrector
has not won but three Cutting Edge
ingredients and goes to work fast to
Target sunspots dark spots liver spots
and even old discoloration both on your
face and your hands you can now enjoy
your summer sun Beach and barbecues
without embarrassing uh spots and all
the rest of it genucel's most popular
package also features their summer
Essentials like the best-selling Ultra
retinol moisturizer with a powerful
retinal alternative for safe use in the
sun you'll be amazed how quickly you'll
see results or 100 of your money is
guaranteed back to you if you like me
are genuinely very very worried about
the heat hell that we are all
experiencing and how will impact your
glowing vacation skin who cares about
the destruction of the planet what I'm
worried about is what your skin your
complexion looks like you should check
out geniusell's wide range of products
especially the dark spot correct after
you know if you also want to look like a
healthy normal human go to genucel.com
walshyt right now to get your dark spot
corrector and the genu cell most popular
package that's genyourself.com walshyt
right now and save over 70 on
geniusell's most popular package all
orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last genusal.com
Walsh YT
but here's the problem whether there are
too many problems to count but let's I
mean here's one
even if these guesses are correct
or approximately correct and that's a
big if
okay they are averages they are not
precise daily measurements
okay ilhan that's not what they are you
can't look at a tree ring ilhan and find
out what the temperature was at 4 56 pm
on July 13th in the year 7 A.D
tree rings are not that specific
just doesn't work that way
which means that the claim that
yesterday was the hottest day in over a
hundred thousand years or 120 000 years
is not supported by any science at all
it just is not there is no basis for it
even the more ambiguous more vague
version of that claim there is still no
science for it there there simply isn't
uh none at all now
so that's all that's all nonsense
but there's one other point that I have
to make here and this is uh so if
there's a tradition of panicking over
the hot weather or at least some people
the media Democrats panicking over it
the other tradition is where it seems
like every year I have to explain what
I'm about to explain here
um and and it and it's this and and I
know for a lot of you this is not going
to be news to you but just bear with me
because there's some people who need to
hear it now here's what I'll tell you if
you're wondering about the hot weather
you're looking around and you're saying
wow man it's hot out where's all this
hot weather coming from I don't know
where is it coming from is it coming
from my my SUV that I drive to the store
is that where it's coming from
um is it coming from all the cows
farting and sending methane gas is that
what it is well I'll uh Point your gaze
in a different direction although don't
look directly at it because in case you
hadn't noticed there is up in the sky
about 90 million miles away a giant
glowing ball of gas which is big enough
to fit a million Earths inside of it and
it burns at its core at about 27 million
degrees Fahrenheit it is uh so big and
so powerful that it's gravitational pull
extends 50 000 astronomical units into
space and one astronomical unit is 93
million miles so 93 million times 50 000
you do the math on that that's how far
this object's influence extends in
modern terms you might even say that
what I'm talking about here is the sun
if you didn't already guess the sun is
the greatest influencer in the solar
system you could search all of tick tock
and you would find very few influencers
who are as influential as the sun that's
how influential it is so here's my point
that big old thing in the sky that
glowing ball of gas we just heard a
comparison to uh atomic bombs well the
the sun generates the equivalent of like
several billion atomic bombs of energy
every second
and that's what caused the shots on
Earth it determines the temperature uh
it determines everything in terms of
weather
and it could get a you know the sun
could get a case of indigestion tomorrow
and burp and uh knock out our entire
power grid send us back to the Stone Age
that thing
that thing is what you can blame the
temperature on
and until you figure out a way
to literally control the Sun
there is basically nothing we can do to
intentionally and significantly raise
lower or otherwise affect the
temperature on Earth
because they're going to be competing
with that thing in the sky there
um and that's that's what we are not as
significant as apparently we're not as
powerful
uh we are not as powerful as
many people especially corporate media
apparently think we are if you'd like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed